こんにちははじめそうです皆さん風といえば中華何食べてますでしょうか
中華まんといえばコンビニみたいなとこあるんですけどやはりコンビニによって味が
全然違う
全部に皆さん何漫画家ですか
おっ
ねと基本やめろ本当にやめやっぱり肉まんとかあんなんだピザまたが色々あるんです
けど僕はべ様開帳というわけで有名コンビニ4店舗のピザまんを準備しますこれがミニ
ストップセブン&アイホールディングスローソンですねこちらのファミリーマートで
寒いまぁちょっとだけでやってまいりました
聞きピザラムールは簡単なカラコンよっ
資産を試食してもう何度行っておりますが私
コンビニ大好き芸人なんでコンビ主の味の判定にはとんでもなく自信あるんですよオイ
サー6 t なるとこなんですけどその感想を含みながら全部食べて味見した後に適当
に穴のたってくせに入られた瞬間何な子顔グラフィット後や桜と思います
天災やまずは試食いてコート方結構みんな違う
てみんなに見たいとがありますね本日の暮れとるはい的に右からミニストップで部
イレブンローソンファミリーマートの順番でございます7だけここにピッツァって書い
てあるんですよ
何でしょサイズ的にローソンがちょっと
ファミマもデカイですね3打目の大差はそんなにないですねただセブンイレブンのだけ
はここにピッチャーと書いてありますたった暫時もほぼ一緒ですね
ただセブンイレブンはここにピッツァと書いてありますじゃあまず味にしていこうと
思います
まずはミニストップいただきます
うん結構とローリーとしてますねなんかチーズのとろーり感が凄い
ピザまん好きだから全部うまいんだよなぁでは逆に甘いものだからこそ苦手かもしれ
ない当てるのが次7いきますいただきます
とろーりチーズでこちらもっきりキーですね若干スパイスが効いているかこれ
ちー族浮かせたるイメージですねやべ
難しいやつにローソンいきますよ子さんはいつまでもねピザ分なんても1年食ってない
からねぇ
肉まんがベースにあるでもそれじゃないんですけどリックマンベース作られているけど
こんな感じですでは次羽目になっていきますいただきます
はからストレスそうですライトな味わいだな
6ず編み的7のことに入ってるかもぜ比較的この明るい味わいな気がしますでは早速
当てていこうと思います
をさせるとかっていいから体格も同じくらい残ってるんでね学するんで生まれまる秘石
今
まあ中にチーズとかあるかなぁあっ機体だったけどわからないから10
んでどれか当てます必ず
どっか行ってみてください同路線にしてここからいきますっ
ブーバー混ぜにしてこちらからでっあああああああっにゃんっ夏結婚ヌー
ラッ
ああああああやっぱたがたわけでバックてくれてそれを当てますダメかって溝キーさぁ
声
はいはい桜まぁそんな始まるわーおいてああ
こっち来る場合それは真面目なんだよねっ
[音楽]
要素じゃないああ
ああああああああ
[音楽]
プロフんじゃないのわかる
中身までもなさそうだなぁ
家庭ですかはいミニストップブーブー
avery 末でした
[笑い]
ああああああ
あー受けて薄子先生のさすがに三分の一だな
あとに残っているあと葉3枚がいっぱい枚が寄せくださいさすがにをいうか
声ゲっぽいやつこれまでや爪ではないまだ
わー
あああございます
ああああああ
none
ん7 e 0
[拍手]
本に訪れるん
ai
me
ううっうぅうううぅ
ええええええ
car
ana あああっ
ひいちゃっ席へ薄いてる本に取ったぞ